hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today we are going back to the
brilliance of video game voice acting
and looking at those guys who bring your
favorite characters to life if you ever
hear a voice in a video game and think
where have I heard them before then this
is the series for you today it's the
Last of Us part 2 a polarizing story
which has divided the entire community I
mean it's never going to be easy to
follow the excellence of part 1 luckily
many great actors have returned to
reprise their roles and some very
well-known actors have come in to
represent the new characters so let's do
this where else could we start but with
the Last of Us part twos protagonist
Ellie the new game sees her step into
the spotlight leading a deeply personal
story of vengeance Ellie's five years
old at this time but there is still no
one better to voice her than the
wonderful Ashley Johnson
it's exciting to me and I I think they
sort of figured out a perfect balance of
how Ellie would would fight and being
her size and she's extremely capable
while the Last of Us was many people's
first introduction to Ashley's acting
ability she's actually had an incredible
start to her career as a child actor
back in her teenage years
Ashley's voice sounded a little bit
different it was quite unique so that
made her a perfect candidate for a wide
range of roles any fans of Disney here
and the classic show recess well did you
know she plays Gretchen grundle er I
know the actors are just kids like
that's right she's been in the movies -
back in 2000 she appeared in the Golden
Globe nominated rom-com what women want
having the pleasure of working with
talented world-renowned crazy person Mel
Gibson in a movie in which he could hear
the thoughts of every female person even
his own daughter sorry Karen
you know we just start ready good good
girl I'm sorry I'm sorry go on yes but
can't be pleasant
another roll of note back in the 1990s
Ashley played Chrissy in the TV show
growing pains
alongside future Hollywood behemoths
like Leonardo DiCaprio who'd want that
besides you got a full house ready and
if I didn't have a place in my own how
would you come visit me huh given that
Ashley went on to win two BAFTAs for her
role as Ellie you would have thought her
career had flourished since 2013 in
truth she stayed pretty close to her
roots picking and choosing her roles
over the years most of her energy has
gone into furthering her voice acting
career enjoying stints on shows like Ben
10 omniverse Teen Titans go and the
recent Cartoon Network show infinity
train they represent but this one just
sits there like a dumb number getting
Dumber every minute that sits there this
is dumb well the game industry hasn't
thrown her roles with the same gravitas
as Ellie she hasn't been a stranger here
remember the awesome standalone game in
the infamous series called first light
while Ashley stepped in to play a
character named Jenny alongside the
game's other leads
played by Troy Baker and Laura Bailey if
they don't sound familiar now those
names will very soon Ashley has also
worked closely with telltale games on
projects like tales from the borderlands
and minecraft story mode if you need
anything you know where to find me none
of us know where to find you exactly and
flex the superhero muscle a spider-gwen
in the late MMORPG Marvel heroes which
was shut down in 2017 ripped the dream
oh and here's an awesome little
reference you might have missed back in
2016
Ashley reprised her role as beth the
waitress in Lego Marvel's Avengers a
bunch of our regulars were happily
sipping their mochaccinos when it all
went down and I haven't seen them since
that's right the tiny little cameo she
had in the original movie is now a
completely playable and thought-out
character four years later
all thanks to Lego okay so let's move on
to another playable character in The
Last of Us part 2 Joel
the gruff but lovable antihero of the
first game returning to the fray once
again of course is the voice actor who
can do anything
Troy Baker maybe I was starting to buy
an at-home cura business maybe I just
wanted to do right by her
that was a musician and I was recording
at the studio and they happen to be
looking for people doing commercials so
did car commercials and just kind of
tripped you know this sunday sunday
sunday and i just kind of tripped
backwards into and been stumbling ever
since where do i start with the career
of troy baker his voice work is in such
high demand that's at one point he was
in every single video game you could buy
became a running joke the funny part is
it was it was kind of true while Troy
has been the mainstay in video games for
many years now you could argue he's the
industry's go-to leading man
because alongside Joel he's also played
Baku DeWitt the protagonist of BioShock
Infinite
my name is DeWitt a friend Troy took
over from Mark Hamill's role as the
Joker in Batman Arkham origins and
sliced his way through middle-earth
shadow of Mordor as talian then of
course we arrived at infamous second son
and his follow-up first light in which
Troy picked up the leading role and they
used his likeness to now mocap is an
industry standard this happens more
regularly these days flush that mean old
conduit for you anyway there's more
ready for this he's played the good guy
in a Call of Duty game the bad guy in a
Far Cry game nathan drake's brother sam
snakes and guns spinning comrade
revolver ocelot the President of the
United States he has done it all hail to
the mother
she oh and did I mention this was all in
a three-year span he must have never
slept he's been in a ton of DC comic
properties voicing The Dark Knight
himself as well as two-face Sinestro
Brainiac Hawkman to be honest this guy
could do every voice of every character
ever if I'm completely honest everything
I built created all of this because I
didn't want any more innocent people to
die
Troy he's so prolific as an actor and so
talented as a man it's not surprised
that in future there's more of him
coming Troy will be playing Bruce Banner
in Marvel's Avengers which is coming
later in 2020 and recently he popped up
as agent Jonesy in fortnight I'll link
his debut appearance now that role could
go for years it looks like the Troy
Baker show isn't coming to an end
anytime soon and to be honest I don't
think I ever wanted to okay enough
beating around the bush there's a new
character in The Last of Us part two
Abbey was shown to us back in 2017 but
we never knew how important to the story
this six foot she-hulk who could crush
your heart with resting face from 2000
meters yeah I admit it I'm not an abbey
fan but to be serious for a moment her
character and actions will definitely
keep us talking for years
Abbey's portrayed by Laura Bailey we can
corner one of the patrols and get
confirmation and then I don't know maybe
find a way to wear him out I enjoy when
there's aspects about them that aren't
predictable you know a lot of times it
happens more with I feel like like
villainous characters if you thought
Troy baker's resume was intimidating you
ain't say nothing yet here's a crazy
fact to kick this off Laura's first
credited voice acting role came back
when she played Gigi and Sarah in the
original Funimation dub of dragon ball
laura has been a huge presence in the
anime scene for years
sticking with dragon bar through GT and
Kai she was in Naruto one piece Full
Metal Alchemist you name it she's done
it such a shame you are a perfect
candidate building up that reputation in
anime over the years opened doors for
Laura in the videogame industry
particularly through Japanese companies
Square Enix rock during for Final
Fantasy 13 Konami brought her onboard
for Silent Hill shattered Memories
Capcom cast her as the English voice of
chun-li for Street Fighter 4 but simply
Laura Bailey was the bomb we have to do
this we have to keep running and running
forever Laura and Troy have worked
together many times such as Resident
Evil 6 and infamous second son and a
standalone expansion first light I wake
up with new powers it was like my body
decided to fight but my mind gave up in
the last decade laura has been
unavoidable she's in everything just
like Troy she played Lisa Jackson in
days gone rotten brownies to trade MJ in
Marvel spider-man you're a scientist a
good one
Nadine Ross in uncharted you have
something I want and you're going to
give it to me in the future things look
good - she's back for the square-enix
Avengers game later this year playing
Black Widow once again alongside Troy
Baker it's a small world next up let's
take a closer look at another new
character in the form of Ellie's
potential love interest Deana played by
Shannon would want one being like
absolute trash how would you meet our
kiss from last night
I felt like I had like Stockholm
Syndrome even after the the the feed
when I was like wait am I allowed to say
that I'm in the game still and they're
really yeah so I was like but are you
sure Shannon has been appearing in many
TV movies over the years landing the odd
episode in other shows here and there
Shannon's career really took off in 2010
thanks to the show raising hope the
series ran for five years straight and
Shannon was there for every single
episode playing Sabrina over the last
few years you have the show might have
been a huge hit but Shannon didn't rest
on her laurels and instead moved from
one critically acclaimed project to
another if you've spent the last few
minutes thinking where do I know that
face from this is probably the answer
she played Elsie Hughes in HBO's hit
show Westworld every time this guy all
the way back home you probably won't be
surprised that Haylie gross who co-wrote
part two with Neil druckmann used to be
a writer on Westworld back in 2016 so I
guess it's true what they say it's not
what you know it's who you know and
everyone knows each other on this bloody
game I'm not jealous you're jealous
okay Troy Baker check Laura Bailey check
next you'll be telling me that actually
Bert she's in this game too oh wait she
is right up there with Laura Bailey when
it comes to the current crop of female
voice actors in the industry Ashly Burch
plays another one of Abby's friends
named Mel what do you need ideally I saw
sutures clamps antibiotics we're far
from ideal right now I realized that you
one could be a voice actor at all
because I was playing Metal Gear Solid
and at the time I didn't understand
because it said Solid Snake and then
David Hayter and it's like who Steve
Peter and I looked it up and realized oh
this is the voice that this is he does
this for a living actually made a name
for herself with a hit web series hey
ash watch her play in which she made
with her brother Anthony when he got
hired as a writer on Borderlands 2 he
managed to get her an audition for a
character we all know and love so much
tiny Tina
this lazy-eyed explosive expert Tina was
the perfect character to kick-start
Ashley's career she's gone on to play
some huge characters ever since
including miss Pauling in team fortress
2 it's falling yeah sure Chloe price in
life is strange don't give me the guilty
face at least pretend you're glad to see
me ray from fought night fighting his
time waiting for his chance to take my
job
I'm Parvati from the outer worlds I
could tend to your engine I know my G
valves for my catalyzers and I can keep
your ship singing oh and did I mention
she's also the voice of a lie-in horizon
zero dawn and the upcoming horizon
forbidden West how nice of you to
finally drop by that's right let's blow
your mind tiny Tina and a lie are the
same person voice acting is a funny old
world isn't it here's a character I
simply had to include once I realized
where I recognized his voice from WLF
leader Isaac is voiced by none other
than Jeffrey Wright try another truce
what's interesting about the show is
that there was this big reveal but if
you look back at the previous episodes
you'll see these breadcrumbs there are
now more fluorescent we're already there
but we're just very subtle hints at
where it was going having recently
appeared in the TV show West world this
piece of casting is probably another
favor called in by Hayley gross and boy
it was worth it a Hollywood actor for
almost his entire career Jeffery is
recognizable for a number of different
roles early on he made a name for
himself in films like shaft alongside
samuel l.jackson you best sleep in there
this oh there you go poppy you're under
arrest for assaulting an office I have
to get it who's the man
[Music]
and he was also in alley where he shared
the screen with Will Smith himself more
recently though Geoffrey's work has
shifted towards the blockbuster end of
the spectrum he brought the character of
Beatty to life in three separate Hunger
Games movies there's always a flaw in
the system
help Jake Gyllenhaal through the
simulation in source code do you have
any idea where evacuating as we speak
and became the Bond series most recent
take on felix leiter appearing in Casino
Royale Quantum of Solace
and the upcoming no time to die seems
someone knows something I don't and as
if Jeffrey's world domination didn't
seem inevitable enough he'll be playing
police commissioner Jim Gordon in the
upcoming DC reboot the Batman with that
shiny guy from Twilight donning the suit
of the Dark Knight yeah that's weird to
me too an actor of this stature is an
awesome COO for any video game and
testament to just how far videogame
storytelling has come okay how about we
turn our attention to someone who wasn't
already best friends with half the cast
a vital linchpin of the original story
Joel's brother Tommy returns and once
again he's played by Jeffrey pious they
have the guys that we would need to do
this smart we believe in Jackson
vulnerable where games right now what
you can capture that the detail and
performance the story is as important as
gameplay Geoffrey made his start working
across a ridiculous variety of TV shows
playing everything from a hard-boiled
detective to a flipping Terminator in
the Sarah Connor Chronicles Catherine
Weaver
sure
his performances caught the eye of many
videogame companies being snapped up by
one of the biggest video game franchises
of all time Call of Duty the lead roles
were few and far between
but someone at Activision clearly wanted
to keep him around
Jeffery appeared in modern warfare 3
ghosts and infinity war before getting
his biggest character in Call of Duty
World War 2 playing lieutenant Joseph
Turner two teams Pearson you'll head
north over the bridge to reach the hill
I'll follow the river with the squad to
guard your advance in fact military
shenanigans seem to be his go-to thing
this is what he does he's appeared in
Medal of Honor games - alright alright
they missed the Train later he seems to
stick to his TV routes though
nailing down roles in two different Emmy
nominated TV shows in the last three
years Castle Rock and the Amazon
original show Vash stay mindful
disciplined on mission one of Ellie and
Dena's closest allies and an important
figure in the new home in Jackson is
Jessie a brand-new character played by
Stephen a Chiang now the big lecture
about my patrols don't go here don't go
there
it's funny how involved he gets whenever
you're scheduled go out suggestion I'm
not sure don't fix the robot fix the
person he's character spans a decade of
various TV shows miniseries and the odd
feature film - while many projects
played to smaller audiences Stephen
started to getting some higher profile
productions in recent years earning a
small role in the blockbuster Captain
Marvel they'll never let you fly then in
2019 he made waves in a different way
joining the cast of the show artificial
which aired live on Twitch of all places
some load the show used twitches live
chat function to allow the audience to
interact with the show earning it an
emmy for outstanding innovation in the
process having already backed this up
with appearances in shows such as
shameless and hawaii five-o
Dennett thomas sorry sorry he Steven
look set to have a bright career in
front of him and there's another piece
of fine casting by the team at Naughty
Dog next up we have one of Abby's close
friends and teammates Owen who is played
by none other than Patrick I think I
said that wrong Patrick fugate's
sorry if it's wrong you're gonna get
your ass over here
sit on the edge or you can go down here
on the kids seat and look at this view
with me these guys were living and
experiencing these missions and their
lives on on the very brink of life and
death okay I admit the name doesn't ring
a bell to me but it might do to you so
here's some info Patrick got his
breakout role in the oscar-winning film
almost famous alongside the likes of
Kate Hudson and Philip Seymour Hoffman I
really confused here all these rules and
all these sayings and nicknames despite
being only 18 years old at the time
Patrick has managed to sustain a career
in major films ever since playing
notable roles in early 2000 hits saved
and wrist cutters most recently you can
see him appearing in critically
acclaimed thriller gone girl Ryan
Gosling's Neil Armstrong biopic an and
the Bourne series spin-off TV show
Treadstone
but have you made your decision do it
soldier thankfully amongst all this he
found time to be in the last of his part
too and crafted a pretty memorable
character so there we have it the core
actors you can find in the Last of Us
part 2 if this was useful and you
enjoyed this please think about giving
us a like it really helps and I'll be in
the comments to see what roles I missed
or maybe just people complaining about
the game you do you I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
see you next time